[Musique]
oui voila merci parce qu'on savait pas
j'ai fait la voix alors tes textes
lancement bande-annonce le rainbow
studios de doublage du grinch on y est
on a fait ces mois s'adresse aux
spectateurs
qu'est-ce qui a écrit ça saigne
bonjour je suis laurent lafitte et je
prête ma voix au grain chirurgicaux dire
franchement je regarde dans une ville
comme votre ville
si votre ville était un rêve c'est super
joli vive grh et le plus bourru et akon
que le monde ait jamais vu
[Musique]
vous êtes méchant c'est quoi ça et
l'échec et mat encore mais que se
passe-t-il
à
cette année le maire que noël soit trois
fois plus imposant
depuis 53 ans noël n'a rien apporté
d'autre que de la souffrance
je sais exactement ce que je dois faire
je vais devenir le père noël pour voler
leur noël s'il peut tous livrés en une
nuit alors je peux tout volé qu'est ce
que le père noël a que je n'ai pas c'est
désobligeant
ceux-ci reproduit de façon parfaite le
champ d'un mauvais rêve
accroche-toi salut toi désolé jeune
butin c'est un renne que je voulais
le grinch c'est la neige la plus
brillante que j'ai entendu de toute ma
vie
qu'est ce que tu fabriques d'accord
[Musique]